round big-time big expert recessions now
he gets it back they get it back to the
corner store now starting to Center
he's hit two threes in the last couple
of minutes I'd get those puppies
organized
look at that tortilla kita no less
playing under the weather today as we
mentioned the starting to come on Clark
on the baseline mend underneath Opera
tries to save it and does is the pace
they want to play at now go go go Harper
means passed everyone and it's off
Virginia just an important force I in
the back to Purifoy he's driving it up
with it for two more and we're down to a
one-point game
quit kidding a different personality
it's a little more motion running on the
baseline here's that little flex and pin
down a little action Brown wants it
I don't know where that's been
he might have been foul to on that
three-pointer it's a little more motion
running on the baseline here's that
little flex and pin down a little action
Brown wants it to I don't know where
that's been
he might have been fouled two on that
three-pointer is pal God contested
the outfits have been paid the price but
how about this little passed by the
little guy number two in your program
right now number one in the hearts of
the Auburn followers they don't have a
speed guy to go to the rim not a hurry
now shot from the border goes down the
one with 6.5 11 for 11 from the line
against Kentucky how about this shot
though to keep him in it his toughest
shot all night Kyle guy knocking down
that three big push attacked the rim at
the other end now for Virginia the
second one two for a four-point lead two
possession game here for Virginia got to
go for two right away they don't have a
speed guy to go to the rim got a hurry
now shotgun before it goes down the one
with 6.5 11 for 11 from the line against
Kentucky how about this shot though to
keep him in it his toughest shot all
night Kyle guy knocking down that three
to roam to inbound then I got the LOB
looking looking it's guy from the car
hold on that is why we got a phone call
desperation shot from the other corner
81% he's tied it this is unbelievable
will the lead
he got all three budgets he's got brown
all the way in the Far Court might as
well heave it all the way the distance a
grant he'll pass here it is brown turns
around it's off the mark and Virginia is
heading to its first ever national
championship game appearance he's got
brown all the way in the Far Court might
as well heave it all the way the
distance of Grant Hill pass here it is
Brown turns around it's off the mark and
Virginia is heading to its first ever
national championship game appearance